Welcome, students,
to the Pharmacology
of Sympathomimetics,
part two.
We will finish up
with the Direct Acting
Adrenergic Receptor
Agonist and then
move to the other
two subclasses, the
Indirect Acting and
the Mixed Acting
Sympathomimetics. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to chat about
pharmacology.
Here are the learning
objectives to
help you get into
the picture of
what you should
be learning about
the sympathomimetics
group of drugs.
Here are the
preparation materials. I
highly recommend doing
practice questions.
It really helps
with learning.
Here are some links
if you'd like to
use them and our
key points organized
according to the
learning objectives.
So let us begin
with our selective
beta 2 agonist. This
is a widely used
group of drugs, very
important group.
They come short
-acting beta agonist
or SABAS, S-A
-B-A, SABAS, an
acronym that has
become a word, and
the long-acting
versions, LABAs.
The ultra-long acting
versions are once
daily compared to
twice daily dosing, but
I'll just refer to
all of them as LABAs.
Structure activity
relationship.
I'm sure you
remember about the
addition of methyl
groups to this point
on the
phenylethanolamine ring.
So we see three
methyl groups here and
these are selective
beta-2 agonists.
They are not degraded
by monoamine oxidase.
I've see there
are quite a few.
Albuterol, Selmeterol,
and Formoterol.
Each has very
important features.
Albuterol is
the prototype,
is still widely used.
Leave albuterol is
this enantiomer.
Its
effect is generally
equivalent.
There's no difference
between them
according to the
clinical trials.
And then
salmeterol was the
first one in the
LABA group, and
others came
along afterwards.
Formotorol has a
particular feature that
I'll point out, which
is why it's starred.
Let's take a look at
the pharmacokinetics.
Oral inhalation
is the major,
major, major root
of administration.
The albuterol
has other roots
of administration
before the
oral inhalations
were developed.
LABA's only
oral inhalation.
There is some absorption
from lungs. The
dose really is small
compared to an oral
dose because there's
a high concentration
that's delivered to
the lung tissue, and
some of it gets
absorbed by swallowing.
There's low plasma
protein binding. You
don't have to be
thinking about that.
Some hepatic metabolism,
whatever, gets
around in the
circulation to the liver.
and the same renal
excretion of unchanged
drug and metabolites,
whatever bit
gets absorbed and
reaches the kidneys.
Sabahs have half-life,
four to five hours.
It generally
has to be used
at least once
every six hours.
And we have
product-specific
half-lives for the LABAs.
50 hours, you can
see, for one of them
that has a very
long half-life. But
the range is anywhere
in between these.
Albuterol has
an onset of, the
literature says,
around 10 minutes.
Some people
find the relief
beginning much
sooner than that.
Now, here's what I
wanted to point out
about for motorol.
The long-acting beta
agonists tend to have
a much longer onset
of action than the
short-acting ones.
We see here 15 to 19
minutes, except for
motorol, which has
a very quick onset
of action, which is
unusual for a LABA.
So that's the
takeaway for motorol,
and that's why
I put a star on
it, so that you
really are aware of
it, and it is a
widely used drug.
So the salmeterol for
motorol have to be
taken twice a day, and
the ultralabas once
a day. That's the
difference between them.
The aerosol delivers
a drug into the
distal airways, as
I mentioned before.
High concentrations
get into the lung
tissue. And it can
be used in really
relatively small
doses compared to what
would be administered
systemically.
They act directly
on the beta-2
receptors, cause
relaxation of the
bronchial smooth
muscle, and
bronchodilation, making
breathing easier.
around 10 percent
actually enters the
lungs and the rest
of it gets swallowed
so why aerosol instead
of oral because
frankly the aerosol
have greater efficacy
much quicker onset of
action and fewer side
effects because the
amount of drug that
gets absorbed is much
lower than that with
the oral drugs. So
there really is no
advantage of the oral
over the aerosol forms.
I mentioned before
they induce relaxation
of bronchial smooth
muscle, but beta
-2 agonists are also
expressed in uterine
smooth muscle of
the pregnant uterus.
And I'll get to
that in a moment.
So why are the long
-acting versions
long-acting? Because
they're highly
lipophilic. They are
able to deposit in
the membrane next to
the beta-2 receptors
and directly
activate the beta-2
receptors over a
longer period of time.
Also, they are
less susceptible to
metabolism compared to
short-acting versions.
I mentioned before
that albuterol
is not metabolized
to any great
extent by monoamine
oxidase also.
Bronchodilation
to relieve
bronchospasm, obviously.
So what patients
would be taking this?
Patients with asthma,
for example.
Patients with COPD.
these are mainstays
for these patients
so bronchodilation
they may suppress some
immune system
products leukotrienes
and histamines they
may enhance mucociliary
function and other
other features
but it's this one
that I would like
you to remember which
is why it's bold
these mechanisms may
appear on board exams
you may see them in
practice questions in
various board review
books glucocorticoids
and leukostriene
receptor antagonists
have better anti
-inflammatory effects in
asthma so if an anti
-inflammatory is needed a
glucocorticoid by
aerosol, so that would
be oral inhalation
again, would be preferred
and it's frequently
used at the mainstay
for maintenance in
patients with asthma.
Okay, I mentioned
before about
the presence of
beta-2 receptors
in uterine smooth muscle.
of the pregnant
individual.
So this is a word called
tocolytic action
or tocolysis.
This clinical use is
to suppress labor,
suppress *********
labor. And of
course we don't want
to suppress labor
a term, we have to
remember that beta
-2 agonist, not the
inhaled version,
can't suppress
labor at term as
well, which would
be undesirable.
So when would labor
be suppressed? It
would be *********
labor, as I said.
So this, we'll get
into that in more
detail at a very much
later lecture. But
keep in mind, this
feature of beta-2
receptors being
present on the pregnant
uterus, particularly
in the later stages.
So, therapeutic uses.
Since we're talking
about it, we'll
talk about the
tocolytic use right now.
Remember that beta
-2 receptors are the
GS type of protein
-coupled receptor. they'll
activate adenylyl
cyclase, increase
cyclic AMP, which goes
on to the downstream
effects, which lead
to relaxation of
the myometrium. That's
the bottom line.
So what's the point?
To delay birth
of this *********
birth by 48 hours.
Okay, so why?
To administer
systemically, by injection,
a long-acting
glucocorticoid to the mother
to promote fetal
lung maturation. So
that if the child is
born prematurely, there
will be a better
outcome, potentially.
and also there are
many areas where there
are no neonatal units
in every hospital
so to transport the
mother to a hospital
with a neonatal unit
so that's what the
clinical rationale
for that 48 hours is.
The effects
on both mother
and fetus are
tachycardia,
hypotension, and
pulmonary edema.
So why tachycardia?
Remember beta 2
activation in skeletal
muscle will cause a
decrease in blood pressure
and that can cause
a decrease in mean
arterial pressure and
that will result in
reflex tachycardia.
Hypotension I
just described,
pulmonary edema,
I'll get into more
detail in a much
later lecture.
Okay let's go back
to asthma and COPD.
Rapid acting versions,
and you see I
included formoterol
here even though it's a
lava because it has
such a quick onset.
For the relief of
acute bronchospasm,
spasm that's
happening right away,
the short acting
version, albuterol,
evalbuterol, or
formoterol, can also be
used for exercise
-induced bronchospasm
prevention if as
needed. So not on a
regular basis, not on
a maintenance basis,
but just prior to
exercise in individuals
who get bronchospasm
from exercise.
Now the long-acting are
really for maintenance.
Maintenance therapy.
for prophylaxis of
bronchospasm with a
glucocorticoid i
mentioned that before
in individuals
who need that anti
-inflammatory action
in maintenance for asthma
that is standard of
care the glucocorticoid
patients who get
symptomatic asthma during
the night And, again,
exercise-induced
bronchospasm prevention.
So those are the major
therapeutic uses.
Many, many people
experience bronchospasm.
And these are just
life-saving drugs and
allows them to have a
regular quality of life.
Now, adverse
effects. tremor.
Well, beta 2
activation in the
skeletal muscle
can cause tremor.
Tolerance might develop
to it, or maybe some
people will just
experience it regularly.
Tachycardia, I mentioned
before, this is
a reflex tachycardia
due to hypotension,
but there is some
evidence that the direct
Stimulation of cardiac
beta-2 receptors
might be involved,
especially with the
aerosol version, since
so little of it gets
absorbed into the
systemic circulation.
Tachycardia is
more likely with
the oral or
parenteral albuterol.
Metabolic effects, again,
beta-2 is involved
with these.
hypokalemia because
the stimulation of
skeletal muscle through
activation of beta-2
receptors will just
cause potassium uptake
by the skeletal muscle
hyperglycemia because
the drugs stimulate
gluconeogenesis and
glycogenolysis in the
liver and that increases
blood sugar. And at
the same time, part
of that whole pathway
is increasing the
plasma-free fatty acids
because of liberation
from triglycerides
stored in fat cells.
As you can see, these
metabolic effects
occur with the parenteral
administration.
Why? Because
there are high
concentrations in the
bloodstream. So the drugs
can activate these
beta-2 receptors,
causing these
metabolic effects. Now,
the tremor, the
tachycardia, the patient can
sense the restlessness,
apprehension,
anxiety, feelings that
come with those effects.
Again, systemic
administration, These
are not likely with
the oral inhalation.
So again, we see
that oral inhalation
really is a
preferable route of
administration
for many reasons.
Basically,
efficacy and much
lower potential
for side effects.
moving now to the beta
3 receptor agonist
this is a relatively
recent addition compared
to all of the other
adrenergic receptor
agonists on the market
mirbegrin is the
one with a star on
it And it is used for
urinary incontinence.
I put a picture of the
really very basic
sketch of the urinary
bladder. We see the
beta receptors, the
muscarinic receptors,
and the alpha receptors.
So autonomic innervation
of the bladder.
You may recall that
the parasympathetic
activation will
trigger, will allow for
micturition or urination.
And the sympathetic
nervous system has
the opposite effect of
preventing the, or at
least I should say,
inhibiting urination. The
very simple
pharmacokinetics here, we
see maribagrin as
a CYP2D6 inhibitor.
Patients with
overactive bladder tend
to be older, maybe
on other drugs.
We see maribagrin's
half-life is pretty
long. It takes a
couple of months,
though, for real
onset, in other words,
to overcome this
urinary problem.
So how do they work?
Activation of beta
-3 receptors causes
relaxation of the
detrusive smooth muscle
during the storage
phase, and this enhances
bladder capacity.
So it's used for
overactive bladder. with
symptoms, symptomatic
overactive bladder,
those symptoms being
urinary frequency,
urgency,
urge incontinence,
and importantly,
mirabegren, the beta
-3 agonist, can be used
together with an anti
-muscarinic drug. So
we're bringing back
a concept here of M3
receptors being present
in the urinary system.
So antagonists of
the M3 receptors are
also used for
the management of
overactive bladder
because they inhibit
the acetylcholine
action on the smooth
muscle and therefore
decrease bladder
spasms, increase
bladder capacity,
decrease urgency
and frequency. They
have a pretty rapid
onset by comparison
and some patients may do
better on the
combination.
Mirabegarin adverse
effects can increase
blood pressure, so it
should be monitored.
And QT interval prolongation,
it's a low risk,
so most people would
do fine if that's the
only QT interval
prolongation drug on board.
But the more drugs that
increase QT interval
prolongation that a
patient takes, the
more likely ventricular
arrhythmia can occur.
So cautions
avoid in patients
with severe hypertension.
So this would be
uncontrolled hypertension.
And patients who
are at a risk
for QT interval
prolongation.
Simple concepts.
Look at the adverse
effects. See what
the cautions are.
These are drug
conditions or drug
disease interactions.
And then, of course,
we have to remember
CYP2D6, mediated
potential interactions.
So let's do a little
check your knowledge.
If you like, you can
pause the computer,
take a look at
these questions, see
if you can answer
them without looking.
So here we go. What
is the mechanistic
effect of Sabahs
and Labahs?
Beta-2 agonists,
relax, bronchial
smooth muscle, and
relieve bronchospasm.
Easy.
What are the therapeutic
goals of these drugs?
SABAs are called
rescue halers because
they are used to
treat an ongoing
bronchospasm and they
will act quite quickly
to do that and LABAs
for chronic use for
prevention of
bronchospasm so what are
common side effects
tremor especially
tremor can occur
with the The aerosol,
tachycardia can occur
with the aerosol.
And tremor and
tachycardia can
give this sensation
of nervousness.
These are certainly
more pronounced with
systemic use. And
the parenteral ones,
we start to see the
metabolic effects.
Hypokalemia,
hyperglycemia,
increased serum
-free fatty acids.
So why is inhalation
the preferred route
of administration
for beta-2 agonists?
I'm sure you understand
this intuitively.
A small dose delivers
a high concentration
of drug to the
distal airways.
Rapid relief of
bronchospasm, generally
slower with LABAs,
but still faster
compared to the
oral administration.
LABAs and ultra
-LABAs have a long
duration of action,
so they're convenient.
and they will
provide that coverage
for a considerable
period of time.
The aerosol are
more effective and
have reduced
adverse effects
compared to the
oral administration.
And the metered dose
inhalers that they
come in, these
little canisters that
fit in the pocket,
are portable and easy
to use once you get
the method down.
What is the function
of beta-2 receptors
on uterine smooth
muscle during pregnancy?
They are highly
expressed on uterine
smooth muscle throughout
pregnancy, but
particularly in the
third trimester.
And beta-2 receptors
are important for
preventing *********
contractions. attractions.
What is the clinical
rationale for
systemic administration
of beta-2 agonists
to a pregnant person
between 24 and 34
weeks gestation as
tocolytic therapy?
Well, you know what
activation of beta
-2 receptors in the
uterine smooth muscle
does, so you know
then that it's to
slow labor the idea
is to slow it down
for 48 hours to delay
the labor to enhance
fetal lung development
that's the goal
of therapy by providing
a glucocorticoid
shot a long acting
glucocorticoid
injection to the
mother and what is
current clinical use
of beta 3 agonists
treatment of
overactive bladder with
symptoms of urinary
frequency urgency urge
incontinence and it can
be used together with
a muscarinic
antagonist what is the
mechanism of action for
this therapeutic use
well activation of
beta-3 receptors in
the urinary bladder
causes relaxation of
the detrusive muscle
during the storage
phase, and that enhances
bladder capacity.
And what is
the name of the
drug that has
the star on it?
Mirabegrin.
Moving now to the
alpha drugs. Now these
are alpha 2 adrenergic
receptor agonists.
Clonidine and
methldopa, and
there are several
others, but
we'll just talk
about these two.
Starting with
clonidine. This is
a far more important
drug in the
clinical realm
than methyl dopa.
Clonidine activates
alpha-2 adrenergic
receptors in the vasomotor
center of the brainstem.
So this is central,
a central action.
So in the CNS, there
are postsynaptic alpha
-2 receptors as well as
presynaptic. The major
mechanism appears to
be activation of the
postsynaptic alpha-2
receptors, which decreases,
these remember these
are G-I protein
-coupled receptors
decreases the sympathetic
nervous system activity
outflow from the CNS.
And of course,
activation of the
presynaptic ones
decreases the
release of the
neurotransmitter.
That's why
these are called
sympatholytics, not
sympathomimetics,
sympatholytics because
they suppress the
sympathetic outflow
from the cns okay so
think about what the
effect of that would
be if we're reducing
the sympathetic
tone coming from the
top from the cns what
will be the effect
lower blood pressure
and reducing all other
sympathetic activity.
But clonidine
is mainly used
for lowering
blood pressure.
And these sympatholytic
actions we'll
see when we get to
the therapeutic uses.
I put this one in
here because it can
appear on a board
exam or some other
kinds of exams and
on exam reviews.
the major mechanism of
clonidine appears to
be its action at the
alpha-2 receptor zone.
So that's what we
need to remember.
So here's how it goes.
Decreasing the heart
rate, decreasing the
cardiac output,
decreases peripheral
resistance, and that
decreases blood pressure.
and also is yeah it's
a so you see it's
acting on the heart
and on the vasculature
so what's happening
when people are lying
down that's when
sympathetic tone to the
vasculature is low
that's just a natural
thing with lying down
so the major effect
therefore would be
the decrease in heart
rate and ******
volume. So decrease in
cardiac output is the
major blood pressure
lowering effect. When
we're standing up
now, there's increased
sympathetic outflow
to help us stand up,
to squeeze our veins
in order to prevent
orthostatic hypotension.
therefore the major
effect of clonidine
would be a decrease in
the vascular resistance
upon standing
bottom line the drug
decreases blood pressure
so what about the
therapeutic uses
okay decreasing blood
pressure so for use in
hypertension however
clonidine is not
first line. It's not
even second line.
It's just an add-on
somewhere down the way
for individuals whose
blood pressure is
not controlled by one
or two or three of
the first line agents.
It's also used
for attention
deficit hyperactivity
disorder.
the theoretical
mechanism is modulation
of the sympathetic
tone in the
prefrontal cortex
enhances attention and
reduces hyperactivity
and impulsivity
pain management okay
how why would this
be used for pain it
would be administered
epidurally and to
the spinal fluid.
And therefore,
clonidine, by blocking
the alpha-2
receptors, will
block the pain
signals to the brain.
So the brain is not
receiving those
pain signals.
Hot flashes and
menopause, don't know the
mechanism for that. It
hasn't been described.
Withdrawal syndromes.
Well, patients who are
having opioid or
smoking withdrawal are
going to have sympathetic
outflow increases.
They're going to
have these symptoms
of sympathetic
outflow. So
clonidine was going
to prevent that.
And some people do
well by receiving
clonidine just to
manage those symptoms.
And then it's got several
other applications.
These are the
main ones. You
really should be
aware of them.
Bradycardia, reducing
sympathetic outflow
is going to reduce
the action at the beta
-1 receptors on the
sinoatrial node. So
that's going to result
in slow heart rate.
Hypotension, well,
we're lowering blood
pressure and hypotension
can result, as well
as orthostatic hypotension.
The hypotension
that occurs upon
standing because that
vasoconstrictive effect
that pushes blood back
to the heart when
we stand up has been
interfered with. This
is lower on the list of
likely adverse effects,
but it can occur.
And dry mouth.
People taking clonidine
complain about dry mouth.
The mechanism
is not clear.
****** dysfunction,
it's interfering
again with the
sympathetic activity.
This is in a red box.
I'm putting it in
a red box with a
double line around it.
So, abrupt withdrawal
of the drug can cause
rebound hypertension
as the drug is
removed and the sympathetic
outflow abruptly
moves into the
periphery from the CNS.
That can cause a
marked increase in
blood pressure
and in heart rate.
So, what do we do?
We have to taper it.
The drug has
to be removed
gradually, with
a dose reduction
gradually. That's
called tapering.
Now, this
interaction with beta
blockers comes up
all the time because
it's a really
important interaction.
I mentioned before
that clonidine is an
add-on drug, and it
may be added together
with a beta blocker
to reduce somebody,
to manage hypertension
in an individual
with difficult-to
-manage blood pressure.
If the beta blocker
and clonidine are
abruptly stopped
together, the rebound
hypertension can
be really severe
because of the removing,
removing, I have
put it down here for
you, removing the
two drugs at the same
time or the alpha
-2 agonist before the
beta-blocker results
in a catecholamine
surge leading to
unopposed vasoconstriction
by activation of
the alpha receptors
in the vasculature.
So what do we
do? We withdraw
the beta-blocker first,
slowly taper the
dose, then slowly
taper the clonidine
dose second.
It makes sense, right?
If you remove the clonidine
first, then you've
got all of this
vasculature alpha receptors
exposed, and they're
going to contract.
now methyl dopa
methyl dopa is also an
alpha 2 agonist but
not methyl dopa itself
methyl dopa gets
converted to methyl
norepinephrine alpha
methyl norepinephrine
using the same same
enzymes that convert
dopa to dopamine to
norepinephrine. But
this has a methyl
group on the dopa, on
the dopamine, and on
the norepinephrine.
That's why it's
alpha-methyl
and then the
other molecule.
Okay, so now alpha
-methyl norepinephrine
replaces norepinephrine
in the storage
vesicle. So when
the vesicle releases
its contents, it's
not norepinephrine
anymore, it's alpha
-methylnorepinephrine.
And that drug activates
alpha-2 receptors
in the vasomotor center
of the brainstem.
So it's got a similar
action to clonidine.
Because this guy, alpha
-methylnorepinephrine,
is replacing
norepinephrine in
the vesicles, it is
referred to as a
false transmitter.
And I can say the
boards really do
like that question.
They may not call
it a false transmitter
in the board
question, but they
will describe it
so you could
recognize it as such.
Paracin, clonidine
lowers blood pressure
and cardiac
output more than
methyl dopa does. So
methyl dopa does not
have much therapeutic
use anymore.
It's an old drug
that's been around
for a long time
before the modern
drugs, even before
beta blockers.
So what would
it be used for?
Mainly hypertension
in the pregnant
individual. This would
be chronic hypertension.
Hypertension of
pregnancy is a subject
for another time. So
just very briefly.
Methyl Dopa lacks
fetal adverse effects.
That sounds really good.
Maintains uterine
blood flow.
Very good. does not
reduce maternal cardiac
output or blood
flow to the kidneys.
So it's got a
lot of pluses in
terms of use
during pregnancy.
Adverse effects, well,
we saw dry mouth,
sedation, I forgot
to highlight that
with clonidine, but
sedation is a big
one with clonidine,
and it's important.
It's an important adverse
effect of methyl
dopa, too.
But methyl dopa is also
associated with
depression.
That's the main
difference with methyl
dopa in terms of
typical side effects.
But methyl dopa
can also cause
Parkinsonian symptoms,
hyperprolact,
anemia, gynecomastia,
galacteria.
If you don't know
what these terms mean,
please look them up.
If we ever come across
a term you don't know,
please look it up
because that will help
your understanding.
And we have some
thankfully uncommon
adverse effects,
but we must keep
our eyes open for
these uncommon.
toxicities because
they can be
potentially
serious, hepatitis,
hemolytic
anemia, aplastic
anemia, drug fever.
These do occur, but
fortunately,
not commonly,
not frequently.
So that's methyl
dopa. You can see
there are considerable
similarities,
but also differences
with clonidine.
So let's check
our knowledge.
I invite you to have
a look at these and
see if you can remember
them on your own.
How does activation
of alpha-2 receptors
lead to reduction
in blood pressure?
Activation of central
postsynaptic and
presynaptic alpha-2
receptors, which are GI
-PCRs, activates
inhibitory neurons in
the brainstem, which
reduces sympathetic
outflow, which leads
to vasodilation and
decreased vascular
resistance, decreased
heart rate, and
decreased blood pressure.
What is the
proposed mechanism
as to how activation
of alpha-2
receptors provides
pain relief?
Epidural clonidine
activation of spinal
postsynaptic and presynaptic
alpha-2 receptors
prevents pain signal
transmission to the
brain. What is the
proposed mechanism about
activation of alpha
-2 receptors in ADHD?
And I listed a
couple of drugs
here that he
used for ADHD.
Alpha-2 agonists may
regulate subcortical
activity in the
prefrontal cortex,
the area of the
brain responsible
for emotions,
attentions, behaviors,
and it increases
attention and
reduces hyperactivity,
impulsiveness, and
distractibility.
So how are they related?
How are clonidine and
methyl dopa the same
and different? And I
prepared this table,
which you can find at
the end of the lecture.
So I'm not going to go
through all of
this right now.
You can pause
the computer if
you'd like to
look at it now.
Pharmacology of
indirect acting
sympathomimetics now.
This is the list.
Releasing agents,
catecholamine reuptake
inhibitors, MAO and
COMT inhibitors.
Looking at this figure
on the right-hand side,
panel A is the mechanism
of norepinephrine
reuptake. So
norepinephrine in the
synapse gets taken
back up through these
doors, through these
transporters, and
will be restored in
the vesicles. Or if
it passes by MAO,
it will be degraded.
this little dot
here is amphetamine
so in panel b amphetamine
gets into the
presynaptic neuron
and causes the
release you see
let me back up
here you see how
amphetamine is
going through the
transporters.
It gets into and
blocks up the
VMAT, the vesicular
monoamine transporter,
so it's the door
to the vesicle.
It can displace
the norepinephrine.
Norepinephrine goes out
into the cytosol. It
goes out through the
NET the wrong way,
the backwards way,
and it can therefore
increase concentration
in the synapse.
The amphetamines
also, while they're
present in the
NET, can become NET
inhibitors and that
will prevent NET from
being taken back up
into the synapse.
And see now, this is
typical of *******,
where it just inhibits
the NET, right here,
right here. So that
prevents the reuptake
of norepinephrine
back into the synapse.
And we have a
number of drugs used
as antidepressants
and for neuropathic
pain that also
block the NET.
And here are a few of
them. You don't have
to memorize these
drugs for this lecture.
You will be seeing them
again in this block.
But they're here to
kind of help you be in
the picture of what
these drugs are doing.
And now MAO and COMT
inhibitors. Obviously,
if we block the action
of these enzymes that
degrade monoamine
neurotransmitters, we're
going to have increasings
in neurotransmitter
that's stored in the
vesicle and therefore
released into the
synapse. The important
issue here with MAO
inhibitors, while they
are effective in treating
depression, major
depressive disorder,
they interact with a
lot of foods. because
they're inhibiting mao
monoamine oxidase a
particular food amino
acid product called
tyramine can increase
and this is can
increase systemic levels
because it is degraded
by monoamine oxidase,
which is now blocked,
increasing the systemic
levels. And that gets
into the vesicles,
accumulates in there,
and it displaces
norepinephrine from storage
vesicles, which then
flow out and can cause
marked hypertension.
So you get a spike in
the blood pressure.
And these are the
wonderful foods
that tyramine is in
high concentrations.
And then there are
COMT inhibitors for
the use of Parkinson's
disease. Same
kind of concept. So
the OMT will degrade
the levodopa, which is
the major Parkinson's
drug, and therefore
reduce levels
going into the CNS.
And by blocking that
degradation in the
periphery, greater
amounts of levodopa
get into the CNS.
And now finally,
the mixed-acting
sympathomimetics.
They are
ephedrine and
pseudoephedrine.
which is an enantiomer
of ephedrine that
has a quarter of
the potency of
ephedrine in terms of
its pressor effects.
So why are they called
mixed action?
Because, one,
they can release
norepinephrine from the
sympathetic neurons
and also, of course,
epinephrine. and that
is the same mechanism we
saw before and they also
have a direct action
they will directly
activate alpha and beta
receptors ephedrine is
used for hypotension
that can occur
during surgery during
anesthesia and it's
available in an over in over
-the-counter tablets
for bronchodilation.
So why bronchodilation?
Beta receptor activation.
Beta 2.
It will increase
heart rate,
increase cardiac output,
increase blood pressure
because of all of its
sympathetic actions.
Bronchodilation, again,
tachycardia,
palpitations,
dizziness, restlessness,
the typical things we
see with sympasomimetics.
Pseudoephedrine,
right here it's not a
postscript is available
as a behind-the
-counter drug you can
purchase it without a
prescription but you
have to show your
driver's license it
is a nasal congestant
it's quite a decent
oral nasal congestion
decongestant by
activating the alpha
receptors in the
vasculature of the nasal
mucosa, and that will
reduce the edema within
the turbinates,
nasal turbinates, and
that will relieve
the nasal congestion.
What are three
mechanistic categories
of the
sympathomimetic drugs?
Direct acting, indirect
acting, mixed acting.
And what are the
definitions? Here
they are. Direct
acting act directly.
Indirect acting cause
norepinephrine
to do the action.
Mixed acting of
both. Both release of
norepinephrine, which
does the action,
and directly activating
the receptors.
And here's a question.
A patient with major
depressive disorder
unresponsive to
standard antidepressant
therapy is prescribed
phenylzine.
You don't have to know
that drug. You just
know the rest of
this. The patient is
cautioned to avoid
aged cheese, pickles,
deli meats, beer,
wine, because consuming
them can cause
dangerously elevated blood
pressure when taken
with the phenylzine.
What is the
therapeutic target of
action of the prescribed
antidepressant?
So that's what
you need to know.
And that is your
choice here.
And it is monoamine
oxidase because
we're talking
about tyramine.
A patient develops
hypotension while having
surgery under general
anesthesia and
is administered
ephedrine. How does its
mechanism of action
differ from that of other
vasopressors, such
as epinephrine,
norepinephrine, dopamine,
and phenylephrine?
Because it has
this mixed action,
norepinephrine
releasing and direct
activation on the
adrenergic receptors.
And here is the
summary. I'm
not going to go
through that.
You can look at that.
and the check
your knowledge
questions with answers.
Hopefully these
will help you.
And then, of
course, I invite
you to do the
practice questions.
And that
concludes the two
lectures on
Sympathomimetics.